RELIANT ON CONTINUAL GENERATION.
SO WE CAN STORE ENERGY WHEN IT'S
AVAILABLE.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT SAID.
BY FORCING A -- THIS IS HOW HE
RESPONDED.
>> A RAPE OR INCEST VICTIM
DURING A PREGNANCY?
>> IT DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT AT
ALL BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT
PROVIDES AT LEAST SIX WEEKS FOR
A PERSON TO BE ABLE TO GET AN
ABORTION.
ONE, IT DOESN'T PROVIDE THAT.
THAT SAID, LET'S MAKE SOMETHING
VERY CLEAR.
RAPE IS A CRIME AND TEXAS WILL
WORK TIRELESSLY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ELIMINATE ALL RAPISTS
FROM THE STREETS OF TEXAS BY
AGGRESSIVELY GOING OUT AND
ARRESTING THEM AND PROSECUTING
THEM AND GETTING THEM OFF THE
STREETS.
SO GOAL NUMBER ONE IN THE STATE
OF TEXAS WILL BE A VICTIM OF
RAPE.
>> I'M WONDERING WHAT YOU
THOUGHT WHEN YOU HEARD THAT.
>> WELL, I FIND GOVERNOR
ABBOTT'S COMMENTS DISGUSTING AND
I THINK THERE'S TWOFOLD.
ONE, I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS
FAMILIAR WITH A MENSTRUATING
PERSON'S BODY.
IN FACT, I DO KNOW THAT HE'S NOT
FAMILIAR WITH A WOMAN -- WITH A
FEMALE OR MENSTRUATING PERSON'S
BODY.
HE WOULD KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE SIX
WEEKS.
I'M SORRY WE HAVE TO BREAK DOWN
BIOLOGY 101 ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION, BUT IN CASE NO ONE
HAS INFORMED HIM BEFORE IN OUR
LIFE -- IN HIS LIFE, SIX WEEKS
PREGNANT MEANS TWO WEEKS LATE
FOR YOUR PERIOD AND TWO WEEKS
LATE ON YOUR PERIOD FOR ANY
PERSON, ANY PERSON WITH A
MENSTRUAL CYCLE CAN HAPPEN IF
YOU'RE STRESSED, IF YOUR DIET
CHANGES OR FOR REALLY NO REASON
AT ALL.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE SIX WEEKS.
THAT'S FIRST THINGS FIRST.
THE SECOND AREA OF THIS WHEN HE
TALKS ABOUT GOING AFTER RAPISTS
AND THIS LANGUAGE OF -- THAT HE
USES ABOUT GETTING RAPISTS OFF
THE STREET, THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE RAPED AND WHO ARE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ARE ASSAULTED
BY SOMEONE THAT THEY KNOW AND
THESE AREN'T JUST PREDATORS THAT
ARE WALKING AROUND THE STREETS
AT NIGHT.
THEY ARE PEOPLE'S UNCLES, THEY
ARE TEACHERS, THEY ARE FAMILY
FRIENDS AND WHEN SOMETHING LIKE
THAT HAPPENS, IT TAKES A VERY
LONG TIME, FIRST OF ALL, FOR ANY
VICTIM TO COME FORWARD AND
SECOND OF ALL, WHEN A VICTIM
COMES FORWARD, THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY WANT TO BRING THEIR
CASE INTO THE CARCERAL SYSTEM.
THEY DON'T WANT TO RETRAUMATIZE
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY GO TO
COURT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO REPORT A
FAMILY FRIEND TO A POLICE
PRECINCT LET ALONE IN THE
IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF THE
TRAUMA OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT.
SO WHILE SOME VICTIMS DO USE
THAT RECOURSE, AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS COMPLETELY
AVAILABLE AND IF THAT IS PART OF
THEIR PROCESS, THAT'S GREAT, BUT
THIS IDEA THAT WE'RE GOING TO
QUOTE, UNQUOTE END RAPE WHEN THE
SAME TYPE OF RACE CULTURE AND MA
SOJ NIS STICK CULTURE THAT
INFORMED THIS TO BE FORMED,
THOSE BELIEFS ARE HELD BY THE
GOVERNOR HIMSELF AND THE TEXAS
STATE LEGISLATURE.
FRANKLY, THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE
IN POWER AS WE KNOW FROM THE ME
TOO MOVEMENT THAT COMMIT SEXUAL
ASSAULT, THAT HELP THEIR FRIENDS
COVER UP THESE CRIMES AND SOME
OF THEM EVEN SERVE IN THE SAME
STATE LEGISLATURES THAT ARE
VOTING ON THE ANTI -- YOU KNOW,
JUST THESE ANTI-CHOICE BILLS.
IT'S AWFUL.
HE SPEAKS FROM SUCH A PLACE OF
DEEP IGNORANCE THAT -- AND IT'S
NOT JUST IGNORANCE, IT'S
IGNORANCE THAT'S HURTING PEOPLE
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
>> YOU CITED RAPE CULTURE AND
MISOGYNISTIC CULTURE ARE BEHIND
THIS TEXAS BILL TO BEGIN WITH.
CAN YOU JUST EXPLAIN THAT, HOW
YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT TO PEOPLE?
>> SURE.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE LAW
THAT WAS PASSED IN TEXAS, WE
KNOW THAT ANTICHOICE BILLS ARE
NOT ABOUT BEING PRO LIFE BECAUSE
IF THEY WERE ABOUT BEING PRO
LIFE, THEN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
WOULD SUPPORT FRANKLY AN AGENDA
THAT HELPS GUARANTEED HEALTH
CARE, THAT HELPS ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE THAT DO GIVE BIRTH CAN
HAVE THAT CARE FOR A CHILD.
WE KNOW NONE THIS HAVE IS ABOUT
SUPPORTING LIFE.
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT IS
CONTROLLING WOMEN'S BODIES AND
CONTROLLING PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
GENDER MEN.
SOMEONE LIKE ME WHO IS A WOMAN
OR ANY MENSTRUATING PERSON IN
THIS COUNTRY CANNOT MAKE
DECISIONS OVER THEIR OWN BODY
AND GOVERNOR ABBOTT AND MITCH
McCONNELL WANT TO HAVE MORE
CONTROL OVER A WOMAN'S BODY THAN
THAT WOMAN OR THAT PERSON HAS
OVER THEMSELVES.
WHAT THAT SHARES IN -- WHAT THAT
SHARES WITH RAPE CULTURE IS THAT
SEXUAL ASSAULT IS ABOUT THE
ABUSIVE POWER AND SEXUAL ASSAULT
IS ABOUT ASSERTING CONTROL OVER
ANOTHER PERSON AND THE EASE WITH
WHICH THESE MEN SEEK TO DO THAT
TO OTHER PEOPLE IS ATROCIOUS.
IT IS MORALLY REPREHENSIBLE AND
THEY DON'T -- THEY CANNOT EVEN
BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND THE
AGONIZING DECISIONS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE TO MAKE IN CASES